In this lecture, we introduce
and develop the concept of
independence between events.
The general idea is
the following.
If I tell you that a certain
event A has occurred, this
will generally change the
probability of some other
event B. Probabilities will
have to be replaced by
conditional probabilities.
But if the conditional
probability turns out to be
the same as the unconditional
probability, then the
occurrence of event A does not
carry any useful information
on whether event B will occur.
In such a case, we say that
events A and B are
independent.
We will develop some intuition
about the meaning of
independence of two events and
introduce an extension, the
concept of conditional
independence.
We will then proceed to define
the independence of a
collection of more
than two events.
If, for any two of the events
in the collection we have
independence between them, we
will say that we have pairwise
independence.
But we will see that
independence of the entire
collection is something
different.
It involves additional
conditions.
Finally, we will close with an
application in reliability
analysis and with a nice puzzle
that will serve as a
word of caution about putting
together probabilistic models.